I cannot see but I can hear the world
around me meet Brian he's known as the
world's best totally blind mountain
biker when I was younger I had
functional vision and I played sports I
had dreams of becoming a professional
athlete and then suddenly when he was 14
he completely lost his sight over the
course of 3 months his optic nerves
inexplicably failed and all he could see
was darkness he wasn't able to bike ride
or participate in the sports he once
enjoyed I couldn't play hockey I had to
stop rollerblading couldn't read the
classroom board anymore my world had
shrunk he had to find a new way to
navigate the world he found his cane
limiting but when he learned to make a
tongue click his world changed again for
the better and it wasn't long until he
ventured back outdoors
I really missed bike riding and I really
wanted to be active I just didn't know
how to do it as a blind rider it was a
goal for me to get off the tandem and
have the experience of being able to
pilot my own bike it all starts with is
it time a sighted person would attaches
to their frame and angle it into the
bike wheel the bike wheel would make
noise in a sound to follow while we
would still actively click eventually
Brian was able to mountain bike alone
and without the zip tied when I'm riding
my bike down a mountain it's the same
thing bats are using echolocation I can
make my active sonar signal by making a
tongue click I start off with trying to
find the object furthest in the distance
and then piece the world together with
things closer and closer Brian has to
enter an almost meditative state and
remain extremely focused everything has
to leave my brain and those sounds are
painting a picture in my head
world of acoustic images he didn't keep
his passion to himself though he's
helped teach over thousands of people to
hear their world a little bigger this is
a teachable thing anybody can do this
and I'm happy to show them riding my
bike was something I never thought I'd
be able to do again and now that I'm
doing it it serves as a great example to
challenge preconceived ideas if you
would like to share this story with
someone who is visually impaired check
out the link below for a version of the
video with audio descriptions